we have not done anything to the
non-governmental organizations that are
getting federal uh grant money and and
they're becoming the travel agencies for
these illegal immigrants they're the
ones putting them on buses putting them
on planes giving them 13 to 1400 each of
taxpayer money and so we should be able
to revoke those licenses of these 501 c3
organizations like a catholic charities
that is operating uh and aiding and
abetting human and sex trafficking here
in the state of texas so there are many
things that the governor could do
so the easy version of this for guys
like us would be okay the biden
administration wants to destroy america
you know the democrats want to flood the
country it's all about demographics or
voting patterns or keep the people on
the dole et cetera i mean do you think
it's as simple as all that or is there
something is this ineptitude is this
that these people just don't know how to
govern don't know what they're doing or
do you think it's something you know
directly nefarious
it is nefarious it's intentional and
purposeful because when i look at this
open borders agenda that was implemented
uh unconstitutionally i mean you cannot
uh give up the sovereignty of the united
states of america by executive order but
then you look at hr1 and what hr one
talks about because both of them came
about at the same time and h.r one says
that there will be no voter registration
review there will be no picture id that
we will be doing voting by unsolicited
mail-in ballots and online voter
registration same-day voter registration
same-day voting and it does talk about
illegals being able to vote and you look
at this infrastructure the human
infrastructure bill where they're
talking about granting amnesty and so by
the end of this year we will be looking
at close to two million illegal
immigrants this is a record high for the
united states of america have crossed
the board and come into this country so
i'm sure some people are watching going
well wait a minute abbott's a republican
he's he's over there has he dropped the
ball on this
without a doubt you have to wonder why
the governor hasn't done a lot better
and we could have seen this coming
that's what leadership is all about
leadership is about having vision and
being very prescient and so you should
have taken all the measures necessary to
ensure that you had our own texas
military department our national guard
ready to secure our border and make sure
that we did not see this flood of
illegals coming here we needed to make
sure that we could stand on our
constitutional right article 1 section
10 clause 3 to be able to secure our
border and i think another thing an
executive order from the governor and
state of texas to declare these cartels
as a terrorist organization because you
know i was in iraq i was in afghanistan
and you know in afghanistan the taliban
uses opium as a means to uh you know
fuel their their their efforts and so
what are they doing here they're using
fentanyl methamphetamines marijuana so
it's the exact same thing we're fighting
an insurgency and they're shooting
across the border into the state of
texas which is an act of war if you
declare them as a terrorist organization
then you go after their resources and
their finances you go after their assets
you freeze it and you seize it we have
not done anything to the
non-governmental organizations that are
getting federal uh grant money and and
they're becoming the travel agencies for
these illegal immigrants they're the
ones put them on buses put them on
planes giving them 13 to 1400
each of taxpayer money and so we should
be able to revoke those licenses of
these 501 c3 organizations like a
catholic charities that is operating uh
and aiding and abetting human and sex
trafficking here in the state of texas
so there are many things that the
governor could do
are you surprised how bad everything's
gotten under biden obviously you didn't
vote for biden but are you shocked at
you know only 11 months in just just
sort of across the board how bad it is
no i'm not because this is what
progressive socialism is all about and
you know when i was in congress uh back
in 2011 2012 you know i just looked at
what they believed in i looked at their
policies i looked at their ideological
agenda and i called them out as
socialist marxists some of them even
communists and of course you remember i
mean people went sideways on me for that
but guess what happens now today they
tell you we're socials we're marxist and
so when you look at that philosophy of
governance i'm not surprised by what
they're doing uh they're doing exactly
what they what they believe in what they
say the the fascism the uh the
suppression of free speech and freedom
of expression you know calling parents
who just want to stand up and make sure
that their kids get a good education
domestic terrorists and that's even
happening here in texas where we have
had two parents in round rock just north
of austin they were arrested in their
homes for just going and speaking out at
a school board meeting this is not the
america this is not the texas that
people want
you know i got to do a maya culpa here
man because i remember when you were
talking about this stuff way back when
and i was a lefty and i was on the young
turks at the time and i'm sure i did
videos on their channel it's probably
saying that you were nuts you know
because you saw it early and and i
wasn't there yet so uh times change i
suppose
well you know they in ecclesiastes uh
king solomon said there's nothing new
under the sun and george santayana once
said those who fail to learn from
history are doomed to repeat it and and
i think that's the important thing again
about leadership and being a statesman
you have to say things that people need
to hear not what they want to hear and i
was willing to take the heat because uh
look i in 1985 i went through checkpoint
charlie and i went over to east berlin
and i saw what it was like and my
background is in political science
political theory and uh this is textbook
stuff what we see happening here dave
and and i think you know kudos to you
for having the courage to stand up and
say hey look you know i can't believe in
this stuff anymore i mean you live out
there in california you see what is
going on this is not what we're supposed
to have in a constitutional republic and
it doesn't matter r d
after a name is starting to mean less
and less it's about how you see the
relationship of the individual to the
institution of government
it's very simple the declaration of
independence says that the individual is
supreme they they are sovereign because
their rights come from a creator god if
you're atheist or whatever that doesn't
matter your rights don't come from an
entity called government your life your
liberty your property is john locke talk
about in the second treatise of
government and your pursuit of happiness
and we've got to get back to those basic
fundamentals
are you worried that just not enough
people care about what you just said
there you know last time i saw you
actually was at glenn beck's museum
where he's put together this
extraordinary do oh sorry what's the
name of the museum they i don't know
uh uh it's the american uh journey
experience the american journey
experience it's it's absolutely
incredible he has a trove of artifacts
that are unimaginable i mean i literally
held the olympic torch that was held by
jesse owens in front of hitler i mean i
couldn't even believe they would let me
touch that thing i mean that's just
amongst the incredible stuff that they
have but when i was there and i saw you
there
it sort of goes to what you're saying
right now
there's a history that we have there are
documents that we have that freed us
but not enough people care about them or
seem to be willing to stand up for them
are you surprised by that what can we do
to reverse that
i think it's starting to happen and you
know i will say one of the the positives
that came out of covet was that parents
actually started to see what their kids
were not being taught
and they started to pay attention and
now for the first time you never heard
about people going to school board
meetings two years ago but now they are
and they're challenging the status quo
they're challenging the institution of
indoctrination and they don't like that
and that's why they're fighting back
vehemently against it so i do think that
there's an awakening moment here in the
united states of america but you know
alexander frazier titler talked about
the cycle of democracies and he said
that a democracy can't last as a
permanent form of government it can
normally last until voters realize they
can vote their own largesse from the
public treasury and one of the the pivot
points uh for that decline is apathy and
complacency and so i think that we've
seen that but it's not too late for us
to recover from it but this this is an
ideological war that we're in there's no
doubt about it between constitutional
conservatism and progressive socialism
and marxism if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell